i i thought
every day or almost every day for a long
time
about
why
we
humans
um
see objects embedded in space-time
so why do we see things
that we treat as independent of each
other
and why do we
see them operate on them interact with
them
think about them
as embedded in this coordinate system
that we call space
and
equally important
why do we see them as maintaining
their identities as things
over this other coordinate that we call
time
carl
um
i have to confess i spend recurrently
most of my time thinking about me um but
in an academic sense you know how do i
work
so
it's a curious mixture of
introspection and trying to understand
why i can introspect uh in from the
perspective or through the lens of a
physicist so i i spend most of my time
dissembling preconceptions the gifts
that
our sentience has given us um
and try to
reassemble them in relation to
physics density dynamics uh you know
that that has to be articulated in terms
of the kind of maths that a physicist
would use which would be effectively
differential equations and the calculus
of variations
and having done that there are so many
um there are sufficient number of moving
parts but not that many but the
combinatorics then lead you to the
the kinds of questions that mike was was
talking about so you know what different
ways could this um
physics of sentience
be manifest what possible ways could it
be manifest and how does that address
the distinction between um
things particles creatures um that would
show
the kind of sense making and to my mind
an important aspect is planning that
this would disambiguate them from other
natural kinds or particular kinds that
don't have that kind of facility and
what underwrites that um
so that's what i spend most of my time
doing i have to say in conversation both
with
mike and chris and other people um
there you can easily get distracted um
in in a rightful way um
by
thinking about that mechanics and uh
exactly what chris was talking to which
is a scale-free way but in my rhetoric
that scale-freeness speaks more to the
coupling between different scales that
mike was alluding to
so how does
this
um mechanics as physics of sentience
which which i understand largely in
terms of probability theory and um
effectively bayesian um probability
theory um so what you have is a bayesian
mechanics how does that basic mechanics
apply at one scale and another scale and
then of course the big questions is how
did the two scales couple to each other
so that that that for me is something
that i i find myself increasingly
pressed upon
largely through conversations and
collaborations um but you know that
doesn't mean that i spend a lot of my
time thinking about that and you're
writing demos or mathematical equations
trying to try to get to the um
the uh the underpinnings of it
mike i see you nodding so what is it
about what carl said so i'm sorry okay
professor 11 i apologize and what is it
that
what is it that professor fristen said
that has you
feeling like you agree with it
well as as usual i mean he said it
perfectly i couldn't uh i couldn't say
it better myself i think that's uh
that's that's exactly the kind of um
uh
research agenda that i'm interested in i
mean that's that really is the kind of a
very good um description of what i think
we're all looking for in a certain sense